[Music]
foreign
whatever
[Music]
foreign
whatever
[Music]
foreign
whatever
[Music]
foreign
they should be able to hear you now
what's going on guys uh we're about to
go into the intro this is how we're
gonna look today because we we got
people showing up so see you in a second
[Music]
foreign
guys Lord addict here with King David
we're talking about Guardians of the
Galaxy part three we got some stuff
going on about Spider-Man 4 some blade
conversation some Fantastic Four and
Jonathan major for uh might actually get
uh replaced in the MCU so we're gonna go
over that a little bit uh so what's
going on King what's going what's going
on this week
what's what's funny is even at the end
of that it's believable like
yeah I see you guys all right talk now
oh we're muted for like two minutes
um
yeah he's talking about beef that's what
he was talking about the poles
yo yo beef on Netflix man you know the
attic is crazy that's a wild boy nah
yeah yeah
um
that's that show is is absolutely nuts
I'm watching that and I'm also watching
uh watched uh the comedy special call of
Monique called Monique
yeah yeah I'm not the biggest comedy
person here recently I don't know I
should I should actually probably watch
some comedies with the situation I'm
going through well yeah you should watch
Comedy laughter is the a great therapy
sir yeah so let's let's Get on um let's
get on with the news man so apparently
Spider-Man four
I might have an August 28 2025 release
date uh yes how many movies uh so what
do you feel about that you know spot do
you think that's a good date
no no any day they drop Spider-Man is a
good date I don't care what it is
so yeah that's that's a good date yeah
and this is how many movies should Tom
Holland sign up for uh they want to do
at least two more trilogies that's a lot
two trilogies two more
um as an actor you worry about him
catching fatigue
uh from the character
so and I know why uh Sony and
um Whatchamacallit went with such a
young Spider-Man
because they wanted him to grow into the
character they wanted to have years on
this guy and and it's working I mean the
deal is working just keep him uh Happy
keep them you know make sure that he's
healthy they picked a good guy though
you know in and out of um is acting you
don't hear anything going on with Tom
Holland you know just you know very
professional at all times
I don't know I just hope he doesn't
catch fatigue with the character and
just wants to get because he's already
been in one Trilogy multiple movies with
that trilogy
he likes it though yeah he does like it
but how long before he don't like it
because yeah you know I just I just as
as many as he's willing to sign up for
and just good storytelling good story
yeah it seems like some people are okay
with being in the same position for a
certain amount of time as long as they
feel like their character is being
handled correctly and they're enjoying
the role
endless growth
yeah you gotta make more money too yeah
well no I mean that's regardless yeah
actually let's get into that man uh how
much should Marvel pay Tom because
apparently Christian Bell got paid 10
million for love and thunder that's a
lot a lot of he's a big actor yeah he's
a huge actor I mean he's Jonathan Majors
is getting 20 million for the Kong
Dynasty
or maybe
honesty yeah he already signed those
contracts so a deal is a deal uh
you think they would pay him out just to
get him or get rid of him
if it happens if it goes that way
because I feel like he would take them
to court
he's going to get his money regardless
all right unless you had a conduct
Clause that's inside his contract then
they there's wiggle room and a lot of
these contracts do have a conduct Clause
so maybe he's supposed to get 80 of
his uh net gross
from the role
I I'm not too quick to judge I I don't
know I've heard so many different things
and so so much stuff going on a lot of
things happen in domestic situations
that you know blur the lines of reality
and you know fiction so I don't know
I think it just comes down to
it doesn't even matter what they feel
Tom's worth what is Tom Phil Tom's worth
because once you get because since he's
been probably the most
the the most balanced Spider-Man and
he's got a lot of bargaining chips going
in especially this many movies in like
Marvel was not dictating what he gets
paid he's going to dictate what he gets
paid and obviously he can't go in there
and ask for an extravagant amount but I
feel like he could ask for a way above
average in the industry and they will
give it to him well you know what um
Robert Downey Jr understood his wealth
worth and made sure that he got
everybody paid Freudian slip again
wealth and worth
um and
now Robert Downey Jr I mean he he
formulated his exit strategy made sure
everybody on the staff got paid like all
actors got paid because of Robert Downey
Jr these movies but they have to live up
to uh the billing so if these movies
keep breaking records then his bank his
bank account should break records as
well
yeah so um apparently there's some blade
info going out there uh King oh we've
known for a while if this movie is going
to be rated R
uh what I want to what I want to hear
from you is uh first off do you think
that a rated R blade is a must and two
yes uh do you think that this is like
you know how like there's different
rated R levels you know what I'm saying
like that one where it's just like okay
this barely got hitting the rated R then
there's that one okay a little bit above
and then yeah the other one's like okay
do we let this in the movie theater or
not like what I kind of rated all you
think Blaze gonna be
harsh language subtle nudity and
violence you think it's going to be
around the same with the original
trilogy was no
you think it'll be more
um well okay well how did how Disney
handles a rated R
it's because of human on human violence
right so for them that is a rated R
movie
I think that's where we get it because
uh fighting vampires regardless to what
even though they are uh fictional
characters it's still portrayed as a
human fighting a human so I think that's
how they're going to see it and and you
know partial nudity you might see uh
some cheek meat here and there and then
cursing you might have a cursor too here
and there and that will push you to an R
you know for Disney because they have
they're really
looking at Disney Plus
right so this movie is going to do what
it does in the box office it's just how
do we put it to Disney Plus
yeah question man you know since it's
rated R do you think they even put that
on Disney Plus or they put that on Hulu
I think I might go to Hulu yeah I think
it would too I don't think it'll go to
Disney plus I think if they start
entertaining this rated R factor with
like Deadpool they're gonna put like a
like a like a Marvel section that's in
Disney plus and Hulu and it'll probably
have all the same things that's Marvel
in Disney plus but it will be there as
well with the rated R ones because I
don't see them put in rated R anything
in Disney plus yeah you're right all
right could be too yeah yeah so
after three different writers King you
know this this this movie's had a pretty
chaotic development cycle uh three
different Riders two delays uh looks
like you know there's some work
stoppages
what kind of Faith you have in this
movie
and blade yeah and blade do you think
it's gonna be a hit I think it's gonna
be uh fantastic
um
a lot of the work stoppages and stuff
was the phases was thrown off
right I think that this movie uh because
of the script changes and the director
changes everybody have different visions
of movies
and in order to achieve a certain Vision
you have to see it through to the end
and you have to get the right people in
place
yeah
um we had the the doctor strange movie
and it felt like a tale of uh two movies
because they had you know two directors
and it did that it did exactly what it
did you know
um say I'm really told his story
and it wasn't a horror film like they
wanted it to be they wanted it to be a
horror film I just hope that this film
stays true to the initial Vision so they
can uh you know put a good film on but I
believe it'll be a good film I think
they have a lot to live up to especially
with the first blade movie yeah so you
know there's actually some more Marvel
stuff and this is something Cog would
like man there's a lot of information
going on about Fantastic Four yeah
um so
it looks like um how do we feel about it
being uh placed in the 60s uh that
that's what it looks like it's doing you
think supposed to be 60s is kind of
crazy to me though but that's when okay
they they will live in an internal type
of lifespan in the Marvel Universe but
the way those comic books were told
they had a purity to it and that's when
like TV was new for us and how the world
was new for us they will explore it in
that uh way uh we were going to space
and
it's it can be told that way they they
are the they're supposed to be the first
family but it could be told that way
because we had different takes on them
so this this could be this could work
and it would explain why they were
absent during all that uh Avengers stuff
right
yeah and uh one of the things that uh
looks like they're gonna start filming
in January
good when do you think the time frame
you would expect in January
probably two years out two years
Fantastic Four we gotta wait two years
to watch that could I could I could wait
who do you think's a good a good person
man who do you think uh
Mr Fantastic
um
the first bad guy has to be the Moon Man
has to be the moment
and and everybody
huh it's rumored as galactic Galactus
Galactus they will probably see Galactus
at the end of the movie but their first
villain was the moment so you think it
would be something like in Doctor
Strange where they introduced uh you
know the uh the dark sorcerer dude and
then at the end of the movie they
introduced that yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah exactly they listen
the first character has to be the moment
they have not made the moment yet they
need to do the moment it's not worrying
about getting to Doom uh don't don't
worry about getting to Galactus you can
talk about Galactus as an imminent
threat coming to the planet yeah at some
point in time but these guys are going
to do something I mean it may start off
in the 60s but they're going to do
something that they're away from the
planet during this period of time and
they're going to come back in present
time
right because these these characters
have to interact with the Avengers uh of
the heroes in present time so it makes
sense yeah they happen there at this
time uh the story is going to be the
moment it has to be if it I won't accept
it if if they
try to sidestep him
you know um this that character is very
uh fundamentally grounded and grounded
another slip Freudian slip because the
more man lives under the ground grounded
in uh Fantastic Four lore and no one has
tackled that villain first
and it needs to be
all right so it looks like um to me I
guess I would prefer a Doctor Doom but I
feel like they're going to save him for
yeah yeah
he's a big bad he's you better not mess
up bringing Doom to the big screen in
the Disney Marvel way and that character
needs to have the reverence it's you
like Doom like I gotta Doom right there
um I have Doom right here I have a whole
cell uh with you know Dr Doom over here
and he's probably my best villain my
greatest villain of all time so no you
have to build up to that character
because that character
he's what Marvel wanted to be the the
biggest bad Thanos was the people's
champ you know
so it does look like we have some uh
some
rumored casting for the Fantastic Four
now what I want you to do king is when I
when I when I tell you the name yo what
I'm gonna tell you right now I know what
you're gonna do
and
if they do this to
my beloved thing he's down at the bottom
cell right there in my Fantastic Four
cells if they do what they think they're
going to do is it start with an s
if they're gonna gender swap
the thing oh in my notes uh the the
rumored for the thing is Seth Rogen I
don't care good I don't he's a guy good
I don't care I don't care so I actually
think that would be a problem if they
did that because they would have to
change that whole character look of the
thing
the CJ
CGI I feel you he's a he's a rock
creature it's it's cool I I don't I
don't care dude do not change them until
I heard some gender swap and stuff if
you gen I would boycott that movie on
the highest order I don't care how great
it turns out I would boycott that movie
I didn't boycott when they turned Johnny
Storm black
um I wanted to see the take on it uh and
it was a good
I like I like my Johnny storms blonde
hair blue eyes Surfer boy dudes Airhead
uh Hot Head guys
um I I like I like it true to the source
material so when they gave me their take
on um
on Johnny Storm and uh this guy that
plays Creed uh
played them um
it was a good character it was a good
change but I like when
um Chris Evans played Johnny Storm
I like that I think he did a good
question is he is the only person to
ever played two Marvel characters
successfully successfully right because
he was believable as uh Johnny Storm
and
his range as a character as an actor he
was able to play Captain America
if you really say you think about it
they're two entirely different
characters completely
completely you know because you have
Johnny
you have Johnny Storm who is a hot head
who is all about you know uh Flash and
he has no substance as a person right
and throughout the books they always
tried to give Johnny Storm substance
Captain America has so much substance
and so much morals and he thinks about
things and he's a strategist and he's a
leader of men Johnny Storm is not a
leader of men and to play both of those
characters and do it convincingly I
think Chris Evans is highly underrated
but he did a great job and I'm glad that
you know Disney and Marvel got him
so a sea tile has popped in can you hear
us Tyler I can hear you guys can you
hear me yes sir sorry shy a little late
and pile up on the highway you know no
problem we got Tyler here because we
told you Tyler will be back when we have
these special event movies yeah he he
actually is the one that gave me these
uh notes for the show that's my guy
I saw him at Pax right yes if y'all
didn't get a chance to see the the
videos go check it out when we did the
live head packs with Tyler there
where are we at what are we talking
about so right now we're talking about
the casting uh it looks like Mr
Fantastic is rumored to have Adam Driver
who was that um with that well what is
he playing because look I don't I know
Facebook names all right Mr Fantastic Mr
so I'm gonna be honest I'm not an Adam
Driver fan all that much
did you see the movie 65 I did not no
see it um I think it should be popping
up right now on one of your streaming
services all right see it and get back
to me all right I mean really get back
to me like as soon as you said I don't
care tweet me text me whatever after you
finish I think that showed his range as
an actor I know kylo Ren is uh is a
misunderstood character I don't I don't
really like him too much because he's
too whiny for me I don't like how they
used his Direction but this movie itself
allowed him to act as his capabilities
all right that's fair I'll check that
out
um so I think I've only seen him in Star
Wars so just going off that not the
biggest fan so yeah she was looking like
uh it's rumored uh
over there missing uh they call Mr Miss
invisible or The Invisible Woman Mr the
invisible woman is going to be Margaret
Robbie so how do we feel about that
because like that's the Harley Quinn
chick right yeah right it's kind of
crazy she's playing a DC Marvel
character I don't know they probably get
rid of her in DC at this point uh but I
don't know I don't I don't I don't see
her as that character I don't know why
like for some reason I'm not with that
casting if that is the actual one
um
this would prove if she has range or not
yeah it would it would give her it I
don't think I'm talking about for what's
best for the character and that's what's
best for the actress you know what I'm
saying I think this is best for the
actress but is it best for the character
as the invisible yeah if she can give
you
Sue storm see all right so the
difference between Harley Quinn and Sue
storm is Harley Quinn is a schizophrenic
schizophrenic uh paranoid delusional uh
ex psychiatrist who
has no boundaries be it uh uh sexual or
or or or on the violent side
Sue Sue Richards
integrity
morals
principle
she's a mother
uh and she's the first the first family
so she's the person that she's like the
president's wife right
you know can she transcend can she do
the Christmas of her name exactly like
can she transcend like Chris Evans did
I want to see and and I'm not going to
give uh I don't I don't think that uh to
say that she can't do it might you know
I don't want to damage the character I
think she has range because I didn't
didn't think when she was going to be
Harlequin she would have held her own
and actually made that movie when she
was going to uh um opposite side Will
Smith because I thought Will Smith was
the big catch going into Suicide Squad I
thought he did a good job
yeah yeah she did a good job I'll give
her that you know because we have seen
her be successful in these variety of
different acting uh Parts I will say
that I'm more open to seeing her it's
just as of what I've seen of her I don't
think she's a good invisible woman but
knowing
because she has done a good job and she
has shown up she at least deserves the
opportunity to do it but to me raw like
these characters isn't like a one and
done type of movie thing like most
likely they're gonna be there for a
minute in the wrong casting can be
devastating to the whole brand three
years I mean three movies
what do you think Tyler
I mean she might be able to do it she
might have the range but she needs to
channel Sue storm she's very independent
very strong maybe one of the strongest
female leads in Marvel she married and a
mom but she she don't need anybody else
so she has to channel that Independence
strong-willed I'm a big sister I'm a
wife uh but I'm also can be the leader
if I need to be and step up and take
care of business so yeah it really comes
down to her range and most of this is
speculation right now obviously we
haven't heard anything from Marvel uh I
she could do it if she has the range I
like her as an actress but it really
comes down to if she's able to pull off
what she's gonna have to pull off
because that's a big role like King said
that's at least three movies if not more
uh from the things I've heard the
Fantastic Four going forward is going to
be the main stay of Marvel going forward
so these are Big rules
I would say by the time that happens and
they'll start introducing X-Men like
yeah they're going to be doing a whole
bunch of diverse things at that period
of time establishing a new Marvel we're
seeing remnants of that happening now
the new Marvel and what they plan on
doing going forward and I think they
started planting seeds especially in the
this last uh Trilogy with the Guardians
of the Galaxy they started planting
seeds in what is to come and what you
can look forward to as far as character
development
so uh Human Torch Mason Gooding it looks
like he was chatting scream I guess
that's the last screen Tyler yeah these
last two screen movies he was the
brother the brother and sister that were
in them yeah yeah yeah the one that got
punched in the mouth the dude that was
on the train with the curly hair dude
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah I'll take
it I'll take it I'll take it I like them
I'll take it I'm indifferent about that
I do think that the Human Torch even
though he I would say is one of the most
like outgoing and one of the most
probably
requires a lot of acting to perform like
his Persona there's like 100 white dudes
in every city that acts just like him so
like like I feel like he's the easiest
used to cast realistically like yeah
yeah I think that I could pull it off
the thing uh rumor to be Seth Rogen
let's go I don't know I'm gonna feel
that I ain't go live I'm not feeling
that I I I don't know why I I mean the
thing is kind of comedic so maybe he got
his little he got his little jokes here
and there listen you're gonna have to
have comedy satire from um the thing and
the Human Torch right you're going to
have to have that because Sue is not a
comedian and Reed Richards isn't either
right so that movie would fall flat if
you didn't have some uh comedic relief
and it has to come from the the the
thing and the Human Torch because
that's where the jokes are in the books
what do you feel about that Tyler yeah I
mean it's all CGI maybe a little mocap
but it's going to be lost CGI if Seth
Rogen has an interest in being in the
MCU why not put him as a thing he has
the voice for it uh he has a comedy for
it if him and uh Mason Gooding can
go well together in their chemistry then
why not those are all really well-known
actors except for the torch that if they
have the ability and the time they're
willing to put in the time to do it I
mean we've already had two chances that
they're Fantastic Four and you know I'm
kind of like a superhero Super Fan when
it comes to a movie so I didn't hate the
original Fantastic Four movies I enjoyed
them for what they were yeah
um but we haven't had one at the level
of these MCU movies so whoever they cast
they have to be really sure that these
guys click well and they're willing to
put in the work because this is their
biggest chance to knock it out argue if
they mess up these casting it will
literally be one of the biggest
devastations to the Marvel Universe
right now how many castings have Marvel
messed up not many but all it takes is
something something with this MO
Fantastic Four is like a dynamic
set of people and I feel like it's
easier to mess up those chemistries than
it is the individual people because
individually they could do well but if
they don't do do if they don't do good
chemistry wise then it's hard how many
times besides like Guardians of the
Galaxy has Marvel made like movies that
are dedicated to multiple Heroes at the
same time that they had to have good
chemistry it has to be the the director
yeah yeah the director has to understand
screen time and how characters interact
with each other and you know for for any
for all the stuff that James Gunn
has uh been eviscerated for
he's a hell of a director and he can he
can do multiple characters and give him
the the right amount of screen time to
show development like no other
so yeah they need the proper director
that can handle uh big characters I mean
Adam Driver uh Margaret Robbie I mean
it's Seth Rogen these are Big actors
like and to be able to give the
development that is needed
oh
like that that director I'm begging for
the Russo Brothers right
but uh that that director
has to understand the dynamic between
group interaction
all right so you know
we're hitting on the the 520 I want to
be about 20 minutes of uh this because
our King got places to go I can't be
that long you know 5 30 got to be yeah
so let's let's get into the guards of
the Galaxy from here on spoiler uh or uh
spoiler alert so uh you know let's start
let's start with our guest uh Tyler uh
you know get get how did you feel about
it man guards the Galaxy part 3 is out
in the wild we all three scene and how
did you feel about it man I loved it
honestly I thought it was great uh I
think I'm more positive when it comes to
YouTube some of the more horrible movies
because there's some that I know you
guys didn't like that I enjoy it enough
but man
it gave you everything you wanted in
Guardians action comedy uh emotion even
some of the recent movies that I liked
that not everyone else liked I could
still say hey this was missing a lot I
feel like this is the prime example of
what they need to go going forward a
director that understands the characters
the actors that want to put the time
into them and the writing and the story
to say this is what a Marvel movie is
this is how we make our movies and this
is what Marvel fans expect from their
movies I enjoyed it I loved it there's
some nitpicking stuff that I'll point
out uh when it comes to like uh Adam
Warlock I don't think they used him to
his full extent I think that was
deliberate though I think that was yeah
because yeah if he would have been out
there doing what he's supposed to the
movie would have been over in 10 minutes
so I think they deliberately like nerfed
him for this movie I don't think I'll
get to win as much all right so King go
ahead King let's let's me and you talk
briefly not much because we try to keep
our opinions
but how'd you feel about it man
I cried
um like four times in this movie
I thought that this movie James Gunn
understood exactly
how you can
um reach somebody reach reach deep
inside somebody and pull out the
emotions that you want to pull out
because uh first of all kids and animals
I'm a sucker for
absolute sucker for and they knew what
they were doing with that hey boy did he
did he not tell a story right from the
rip
um
first of all I'm I'm on record saying
this is the best Trilogy that Marvel
Disney has to offer right from the first
movie to the second movie to the third
movie it built from a crescendo
and and it gave you everything
I will put this Trilogy up against any
Trilogy in Marvel
because you know Captain Marvel Captain
America
had to drop off one movie was a drop off
the first one yeah uh Thor had a drop
off in uh the Dark World
yeah this is the second movie uh you
know it's just
there's always uh oh but this one not
Guardians of the Galaxy Guardians of the
Galaxy has a great formula I you know
when we head out because this is this
was I I don't really want to focus too
much on spoilers because I do feel like
when we do spoilers we scare people out
of the room yeah so for the most part
the reason I say spoilers is because you
get in case someone slips you've been
warned but for the most part we're going
to try to stay away from spoilers I
liked it um first off I will say I think
people are capping on the internet it is
a good movie it's a fantastic movie and
I and you know people using statements
like it's it's the best since uh since
before phase four you're right but at
the end of the day
that's not really saying much I would
say the only movie that was better than
this in phase four was was Spider-Man
yeah better than this though I think
Spider-Man was better than this I
thought Spider-Man was good I thought
Spider-Man was an apex predator but this
movie it's uh um
it's a monster of a movie because you
had the McGuffin you thought Adam
Warlock was the McGuffin that they was
going to use to take down the high
evolutionary but they gave you the
McGuffin inside the movie so early on
that you were overlooked it when the
Moment of Truth happened and you thought
back to it and was like they showed it
to me and I didn't recognize it for what
it was and I thought it was something
trivial but it wasn't something trivial
it was something that was integral to
the film but date you fell for the
low-hanging fruit in Adam Warlock
thinking this is going to be the reason
why because after they uh did something
to animals warlocks lineage he had the
the motivation to finish off uh the high
evolutionary and get past uh what
happened to him
the truth of motivation was what
happened to Rocket and how that affected
the whole team when they got a chance to
see exactly what happened to Rocket and
the reason why rocket is who he is and
why he's so angry and why he's so
standoffish and why he's
who he is we got a a real reason
and it was a real reason for them all to
hate the high evolutionary so when the
end scene happens
that's the reason why it had to happen
how it did they wasn't ducking any Fades
and they and they went into this uh we
have the the Angry therapist empty
what's up brother with the five dollar
Super Chat I love this movie it shows
everyone's growth over all the movies
perfectly set great great great thing to
say I do feel like they did a fantastic
job with it uh obviously the ending is
up is open for interpretation on what
happens what I like is like they did
something where it's like look we're
putting this down but we could pick it
up at any time baby you know what I'm
saying oh no I think that's the end of
them
I think that they'll be together in the
same movie ever again but I think
they'll use them individually from time
to time you talk about the characters
themselves after what they did okay so
there's something called the king Wars
right and that's um
a book that uh I think it's
the king k-i-n-g oh I was going to say
what what was the General that was on
IOP was he on that Captain king
um it's uh okay so the king Wars uh
precipitates
um Annihilation and they took a lot
James Gunn is a very astute comic book
reader and respects the law of the comic
books especially down to Aesthetics of
the costumes and he did so because the
costumes that you saw in this movie was
from the king's War which was really
done well uh that book totally different
he takes his own take on it but the
growth in the characters there was more
cerebral and he took that cerebral
approach because you have mantis growing
you had nebula grow into the person that
she was supposed to be even Gamora who
is not the Gomorrah that we know had a
level of growth in that character but
stayed true to Gamora from the books who
we expected her to be Star-Lord had
growth would come into grips with what
is transpiring you know of course rocket
and group We're Not Gonna
Overlook the fact that he went from baby
group to teenage group to uh he went
from like regular group to baby group to
teenage group to like around where he
was at the beginning to oh my God what
is that yeah yeah
so I I feel you on that man I feel you
guys on that I think that uh it was a
solid uh Foundation of a movie
um I like how they entertain like the
Gamora and Star-Lord thing but they yeah
they left that up for interpretation
it's like he's starting to slowly win
her over again but then they're like
okay we're gonna let you guys decide
what happened with that like yeah so
Tyler you know we're closing out here
soon uh what what do you think
talking about like popcorn wise yeah
yeah
um
you know obviously five is the highest
that we give here
um
I'm gonna have to say
I'm gonna have to say five I don't
usually do that but because you know I
always think something can be better for
most of the time but boy if you're gonna
give something five this is the closest
you're gonna get to it I feel like
everything they did just hit you laughed
when you're supposed to laugh you got
emotional when you're supposed to get
emotional I mean every aspect of this
movie just hit you in the fields one way
or another so for me it'd be five for
sure what about you King what is yours
is it five with Tyler are you gonna be
reasonable with addicts
um I have to address people talking
about Adam Warlock
what you got in this movie from Adam
Warlock is called him his he's when he
when Adam Warlock was initially
introduced and he fought Thor
he was named him h-i-m
and that's the the character you got
here is he like Laura Wise just as
strong as Thor or stronger stronger
yo if you so the stuff that you saw him
doing that's some in his infancy because
he came out of that cocoon too early
he's gonna go back into cocoon he's
going to come out as Adam he's going to
come out as warlock he's mentally He's A
Mental [__] right now because his his
growth was stunted by coming out I like
how they did it I like how they did it
they explained it they they introduced
him as a character and gave plot to why
he ain't clapping people like exactly
but he but he showed up and he didn't
think they put it picked a good person
to play him
yeah I liked him yeah he he he he did a
good job
I I love the power set I love the fact
that they showed his power set and I
know a lot of people are going to say he
was supposed to body the high
evolutionary use your mind please the
high evolutionary used a fundamental
element to neutralize
uh Adam warlock's superiority and not to
mention he knew his weakness too like he
exactly how to handle at him like yeah
and he did it with no problem very
quickly very own very decisive in
calculating like a high evolutionary
supposed to be he was dominant I give it
five popcorn if I can give it six
popcorn I will I'm gonna go see it again
uh this week I'm gonna uh take all my
boys to go see it
um and you know gonna go to the boxing
gym and go go watch some uh Guardians of
the Galaxy
if I can give it six I would give it six
I throw James Gunn
as a director
gave everybody the screen time and and
the ability to grow uh he was a blessing
I I wish whatever happened to him didn't
happen to him I wish he would have been
able to take over phase four
because I get a chance to see exactly
what his style is and how truly blessed
Warner Brothers is uh to get him and I
ain't no fault fact if he brings I
cannot wait to see what his Superman
movie is going to be
because this guy is a is a is a master
director and he and this was how you
direct he showed you how you direct and
it's every little scene from them
putting up the sign of Guardians of the
Galaxy to what happens to that sign and
how you feel because they had Pride
putting it up so it introduced little
things to it the guy is a master so
James guns you don't have to look any
further than the fact that DC chose to
choose the him over the Rock
you're an egotistic Maniac you want
everything revolved around you this dude
actually wants to build a universe like
yes and he probably already had it laid
out and showed it to him on the table
Yeah so I think what comes to me I'm
gonna give it a four uh uh you get that
key okay we have the angry therapist MD
with the five dollar Super Chat thank
you so much it's a super five dollars
um I am now more excited for James Gunn
in the Superman movie see look at like
minds think the same angry
therapists think the same I think when
it comes to it
the reason I'm giving it a four is
because I felt like
They promoted this as like the end-all
be-all we're putting everything on the
line and I felt like there was nothing
on the line by the end of the movie
because because you didn't get
you didn't get I'm trying not to spoil
it for anybody that didn't see it you
didn't get what you thought would happen
yeah and that that's more about like
personal expectations but the way they
marketed it made me feel that way
good marketing so before still a
fantastic movie I I think this is
definitely worth watching in the movie
theater uh most like definitely go watch
at the movie theater it's it's the best
Marvel movie they've made in a long time
like like overall General good Marvel
movie you know I might like the
internals but it's got a lot of flaws
but this is an overall good movie
what's going on with you man
oh we have uh Devin Haney versus uh
lomachenko on the 20th it's going to be
a crazy fight so combat talk with the
King will be there Iron Lord's podcast
Sundays at 1pm if you didn't see the
last show go see it so you can
understand who Captain King is and you
must Hold the Line it will definitely
bring tears to your eyes and uh laughter
to your stomach so make sure you don't
have to fart because it's gonna come out
and Tyler man what's going on with you
man not not much you guys see me when I
come on here and besides that you guys
will see me in the chats I don't wear a
podcast I'm usually watching if I'm not
on here I'm definitely watching and
talking to everybody so uh that's really
about it
so yeah and you know I want to thank
everyone for coming through we add up to
like I think 50 some in here you know
the show's growing uh we we're going to
find good ways of uh having fun on this
show Mama sent you guys over their
wandering Dutch man you know go over
there tell them uh tell them attic King
tell them uh Tom r r sent you uh we we
got 15 000 subscribe we're about to give
away a console we said once we get to 15
000 it's a console coming up and listen
listen man if you're down for that PC
Master race you might get a steamed at
so we're gonna go ahead and end it on
that I'm gonna send you guys over there
to wander